[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mehr geht nicht mehr Geschlossenheit das
sollte wohl der Überraschungsbesuch des
US-Präsidenten heute in der Ukraine
zeigen noch nie ist ein US-Präsident in
die Hauptstadt eines Landes geflogen in
dem gerade ein Angriffskrieg tobt Joe
Biden wollte es unbedingt
und damit einen schönen guten Abend seit
Monaten wurde an dieser geheimreise
gearbeitet von kleinen Teams aus dem
Pentagon CIA NSA dem Secret Service und
Mitarbeitern des Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats eine undercover Reise
von der man in Zeiten von Social Media
Datenerfassung und Co kaum noch geglaubt
hätte dass sie wirklich möglich ist und
damit das Unmögliche nicht eventuell
doch noch passiert wurden sogar die
Russen kurz vorher über den Besuch
informiert ein Beschuss der Hauptstadt
während der US-Präsident zu Besuch ist
die Folgen wären wohl kaum abzuschätzen
etwas besser abzuschätzen ist allerdings
was dieser Kurzbesuch bringt jedenfalls
etwas mehr als nur schöne Bilder und
Gesten wie heikleber berichtet
der Überraschungsbesuch schlechthin bis
zuletzt top secret und doch perfekt
inszeniert sogar die Krawatte in den
Nationalfarben der Ukraine US-Präsident
Joe Biden in Kiew symbolträchtiger
geht's kaum die klare Botschaft an Putin
der Westen steht fest zur Ukraine ein
Zeichen auch für die geschundene
ukrainische Bevölkerung die seit knapp
einem Jahr unter Beschuss steht
historisch rechtzeitig und mutig nannte
lensky beiden Besuch
er
es ist so ein wichtiges Signal für uns
wir sind stolz und danken Ihnen dass Sie
gekommen sind das ist ein riesiger
Moment für die Unterstützung der Ukraine
ich bin hier um unsere uneingeschränkte
Unterstützung für Demokratie
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
zu bekräftigen
die
etwa fünf Stunden dauerte ein Albtraum
für die Sicherheitskräfte noch nie
reiste ein US-Präsident in ein
Kriegsgebiet ohne US-Truppen am Boden
Russland sei erst kurz zuvor informiert
worden das Treffen mit dem Kirchen
Oberhaupt der von Moskau unabhängigen
orthodoxen Kirche der Ukraine auch das
kein Zufall
Luftalarm über dem Himmel in Kiew als
die beiden Präsidenten das berühmte
Michaels Kloster verlassen auf dem Weg
zur gedenkmauer für gefallene Soldaten
Kranzniederlegung und innige Umarmung
Amerika leistet den allergrößten Anteil
der Hilfe für die Ukraine fast ein Jahr
nach Putins Angriff die Allianz
beschwören Mut machen
ein Jahr später Kiew steht die Ukraine
steht Demokratie steht amerika steht auf
eurer Seite und die Welt steht auf eurer
Seite
auch das Thema der Gespräche eine
weitere halbe Milliarde US-Dollar hat
der Präsidentin Gepäck für noch mehr
Waffen aber nicht die die sich die
Ukraine auch noch wünscht Kampfjets und
Langstreckenraketen
wir müssen zusammen mit Präsident beiden
und den Verbündeten alles tun damit eine
demokratische Welt diesen historischen
Kampf in der Ukraine gewinnt
die Innenstadt fast menschenleer für den
mächtigen Mann aus Amerika zuletzt noch
ein Abstecher zur sogenannten alides
Mutes eine Gedenkplatte nun auch für den
US-Präsidenten inklusive des heutigen
Datums eine gut geplante geheime Mission
die mit Sicherheit einen Eintrag in den
Geschichtsbüchern finden wird
ein Besuch der Fragen offen lässt die
wir jetzt klären wollen und zwar mit für
Bega in Moskau und mit Katrin Eigendorf
in Kiew beginnen wir in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt Kathrin Symbolkraft klar aber
was denn wirklich darüber hinaus
nun ja das klar Angebot die Ukraine noch
mal deutlich mehr mit Waffen zu
unterstützen immerhin eine halbe
Milliarde Dollar hat der US-Präsident
hier den Ukrainern noch mal zugesagt für
wichtige Munition für
Artilleriegeschosse für Panzerabwehr
also Waffen die die Ukraine im Moment in
ihrer jetzigen Lage dringend braucht
aber trotz der Höhe dieser Summe muss
man sagen dass die Symbolkraft über
allem stand für die Ukraine kommt dieser
Besuch zu einem sehr wichtigen Zeitpunkt
in vier Tagen jetzt sich der Jahrestag
des Kriegsbeginns ein Jahr für die
Ukraine mittlerweile den Krieg Abwehr
Krieg gegen die russischen Invasionen
und deswegen hat das noch mal eine ganz
besondere Symbolkraft das damit eines
der ranghöchsten eigentlich einer der
ranghöchsten Vertreter der westlichen
Welt hier in der Ukraine zu Gast ist mit
extremen Sicherheitsauflagen das hat man
hier in der Ukraine heute wirklich sehr
sehr wir ja als sehr sehr große Geste
angesehen also man hat es gerne gesehen
und man hat sicherlich auch gerne gehört
dass selensky dann auch gesagt hat das
Gespräch bringt uns dem Sieg näher für
Bega damit nach Moskau in Moskau wird
man wie immer hingeschaut und auch
hingehört haben und sich wahrscheinlich
auch wie immer nichts anmerken lassen
oder
ungefähr so was zu diesem für
unangenehme Situationen recht typischen
Kreml Schweigen kam dann aber noch eine
andere kommunikative Komponente nämlich
die Kreml treuen Kommentatoren die haben
entlang der gängigen Propaganda
narrative heute Witze verbreitet darüber
z.B das zelinsky eine Marionette der USA
sei und dass der Chef jetzt eben mal
nach dem Rechten habe sehen wollen diese
Versuche beides Besuch klein zu reden
die können aber nicht darüber hinweg
täuschen dass mit diesem Besuch aber
auch z.B mit den beschlossenen
Panzerlieferungen und auch mit der
demonstrativen Einigkeit auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz zuletzt
Signale gesendet wurden die auch hier in
Moskau angekommen sein müssen nämlich
dass der Westen weitaus geschlossener in
seiner Unterstützung für die Ukraine da
steht als Moskau sich das wohl zu Beginn
des Krieges ausgemalt hatte da wird das
Verhältnis zu China natürlich immer
bedeutender der Kreml Sprecher Schloss
heute zumindest mal nicht aus das Putin
in den letzten Tagen mit Pekings
oberstem Diplomaten Zusammentreffen
könnte ob es dann um die von China
angekündigte Friedensinitiative gehen
soll oder um Waffenlieferungen das sagte
pescov allerdings nicht
und was wir von Katrin Eugendorfer
gehört haben Waffen oder Raketen wird es
definitiv aus den USA in Richtung
Ukraine geben vielen Dank an euch beide
was aber wenn alle Bemühungen dann
vielleicht doch nichts bringen was wenn
Russland die nächste Grenze
überschreitet und zwar die zur Republik
Moldau jetzt mögen sie eventuell denken
ja gut Moldau ist doch weit weg und was
geht mich das überhaupt an das ist der
Ton der auch nach der Annexion der Krim
2014 ja insbesondere im Westen
angeschlagen wurde und wozu der dann
geführt hat und das geführt hat sehen
wir nun seit fast einem Jahr und so
lohnt sich ein vertiefender Blick auf
diese sehr kleine Ex soweit Republik
flächenmäßig gerade mal so groß wie
Nordrhein-Westfalen liegt Moldau mit
ihren gut 2,6 Millionen Einwohnern
zwischen Rumänien und der Ukraine in der
Zwickmühle ist sie aber bei Russland
traditionell ein großen Einfluss in
Moldau hat
insbesondere auf die abtrünnige Region
transistrieren in der auch seit 30
Jahren russische Soldaten stationiert
sind die Präsidentin des Landes warnte
sogar vor russischen Umsturz Plänen auch
darüber habe ich mit dir heute
gesprochen zuvor aber Sebastian eben
über ein gespaltenes Land
es ist der Versuch dem russischen
Einfluss jeden Tag zu entgehen um Punkt
13 Uhr überqueren vier Busse diesen
Checkpunkt
120 Schüler Reisen ein um im
moldauischen Dorf doroska ja zur Schule
zu gehen seit vielen Jahren muss
Schuldirektorin
eleonoracekavskaya das Beobachten und
organisieren transistische Schüler gehen
am Nachmittag zur Schule während die
moldauischen am Vormittag dran sind
Grund für die Teilung der Schule in
Transnistrien wollten die Behörden den
Unterricht in kyrillischer Schrift je
näher an Russland desto besser keine
Option für die Schulleiter
der Unterschied dort ist dass die Kinder
feindselig gegen alles erzogen werden
Sie lernen dass sie von Feinden umgeben
sind gegen Europa gegen Amerika gegen
Moldawien gegen alles
manche Eltern den transistrieren wollen
das nicht und schicken ihre Kinder über
den Jackpot dafür nehmen sie vielen Kauf
Schule bis zum frühen Abend Zeit für
Freizeit bleibt so kaum
der Riss der durch die Schule in doroska
ja geht ist symbolisch für ganz Moldau
50 Prozent des Landes sind pro
europäisch 50 Prozent pro russisch seit
knapp drei Jahren ist Meyer Sando
Präsidentin sie will das Land in die
Europäische Union führen
russland hat etwas dagegen und setzt
Moldau immer wieder mit hohen Gaspreisen
unter Druck die arme Bevölkerung kann
sich das nicht leisten hinzu kommen
gezielte
Desinformationskampagnen und pro
russische Propaganda erst vergangene
Woche trat die Regierung von
Premierministerin gabrielica wegen
fehlenden Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung
zurück
doch den prorussischen Kräften im Land
Recht das nicht sie wollen den Rücktritt
von Meyer Sando mit populistischen
Forderungen mobilisiert die
Oppositionspartei Schur die Menschen
gestern waren es Tausende auf den
Straßen der Hauptstadt chisinos die
showpartei übernimmt die russische
Propaganda sie hetzt gegen den Westen
die Nato und vor allem gegen die
Präsidentin
[Musik]
Diktatur die Herrschaft dieser Frau soll
beendet werden sie soll stattdessen in
die Küche und Suppe kochen anstatt ein
kleines Land zu regieren
die Regierung das sind alles Verräter
sie wollen Moldau zerstören sehen sie
das nicht und sie werden unterstützt von
Amerika
noch bleiben die Demonstrationen
friedlich doch die Stimmung in Moldau
ist aufgebracht
Präsidentin Sando steht unter Druck ihre
Gegner im eigenen Land haben einen
mächtigen Verbündeten der die
proeuropäische Regierung wohl nur zu
gerne scheitern sehen würde
erst die Ukraine dann die Republik
Moldau ein Szenario das denkbar ist auch
für die Präsidentin der Republik und
damit einen guten Abend Maja Sando
guten Abend die Ukraine hält uns in
Sicherheit das haben sie auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gesagt
sehen sie sich wirklich durch Russland
militärisch bedroht
die russische Armee von unserer Grenze
fernhält gibt es keine direkte
militärische Bedrohung für uns die
Ukraine hält uns sicher sie sagten keine
direkte Bedrohung es scheint aber doch
eine Bedrohung von innen heraus zu geben
immerhin heißt es sie hätten Angst vor
einem Umsturz zum Beispiel auch durch
pro russische Separatisten woran machen
Sie das fest
das ist nichts Neues und das Russland
ein Hybriden Krieg gegen mein Land führt
wir haben Erfahrungen mit Erpressung mit
den Gaslieferungen wir sehen diese
russische Propaganda und Desinformation
es gab bezahlte Demonstranten wir sahen
Cyber-Attacken wir haben hunderte
falsche Bombenalarm gesehen
und erst kürzlich die Information über
Russlands planen unser Land zu
destabilisieren nur eines der Elemente
dieses Hybriden Krieges
wir wissen dass Russland nicht mag dass
wir Teil der EU werden wollen
und man versucht uns von diesem Plan
abzubringen
möglicherweise wird auch der Besuch des
US-Präsidenten beiden die aktuelle
Situation nicht sofort beeinflussen
heute war ja ein Überraschungsbesuch
davon wussten relativ wenige wie
schätzen Sie diesen Besuch ein das heißt
jetzt sei ein sehr starkes Symbol
natürlich Richtung Moskau aber auch
Richtung Peking wie lesen Sie diesen
Überraschungsbesuch
in der Tat ein sehr starkes Signal der
Unterstützung zuerst einmal für die
Ukraine für die mutigen Ukrainer aber
auch für die gesamte Region ein sehr
starkes Signal die Länder werden für
Freiheit und Demokratie kämpfen und man
lässt sie nicht alleine die Ukraine
braucht alle Unterstützung damit sie die
Territorien wieder erlangen können und
die demokratische Welt hilft dabei
die Ukraine ist genauso wenig wie Sie
Mitglied in der NATO Sie also Ihre
Republik ist dazu noch militärisch
neutral das Verteidigungsbündnis also
die Nato hat jetzt dennoch entschieden
sie weiterhin auch zu unterstützen
allerdings nicht militärisch ist dieses
Hilfspaket das helfen soll diesen
Hybriden Bedrohungen aus Russland etwas
dagegen zu setzen ist das nicht
möglicherweise doch auch eine Art
Provokation für Putin
ist ein neutrales Land das ist richtig
aber wir brauchen die Möglichkeit unsere
Bevölkerung zu verteidigen das heißt die
Kapazität im Verteidigungssektor wird
verstärkt wir haben eine langfristige
Kooperation mit der NATO arbeiten aber
auch mit nato-mitgliedsländern und
anderen Staaten und bekommen
Unterstützung das Budget wird erhöht für
den Verteidigungsbereich denn wir sehen
diese echte Bedrohung und wir wissen
dass wir eine stärkeren
Verteidigungssektor im Land brauchen und
werden sie denn ihre militärische
Neutralität aufgeben
heute sagt die
Mehrheit unserer Bevölkerung dass die
Neutralität erhalten werden soll das
respektieren wir das ist die Stimme des
Volkes gleichzeitig müssen wir unser
Bestes geben um unsere Bevölkerung zu
schützen wir werden weiterhin sagte ich
bereits unseren Verteidigungssektor
stärken
frau Präsidentin jetzt ist es ja so dass
wir über vieles reden über immer weitere
und mehr Sanktionen mehr Waffen
Friedensgespräche die scheinen irgendwie
nicht statt zu finden auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz auf der ja auch sie
waren wäre ja so ein Ort gewesen
Russland war aber nicht eingeladen
finden Sie das richtig oder sagen Sie es
ist eine vertane Chance
wir alle wollen Frieden wir wollen
nachhaltigen Frieden und wir wollen
dass die internationalen Regeln
respektiert werden die Grenzen und
Unabhängigkeit der Staaten muss
respektiert werden deshalb müssen wir
aktuell alle der Ukraine helfen das
Territorium wieder zu erlangen wir
wollen und brauchen Frieden dieser
Frieden soll ein nachhaltiger Frieden
sein wir sollten keinen Frieden bekommen
den Russland nicht respektiert oder in
drei bis sechs Monaten doch nicht mehr
respektiert
dann frage ich noch mal anders nach
haben Sie denn noch einen direkten Draht
nach Moskau also haben sie eine
Gesprächsleitung zum russischen
Präsidenten sprechen Sie
kommunizieren über unsere Botschafter
unsere Botschaft in Moskau und die
russische Botschaft hier in Chisinau
dann sage ich gut dass wir heute
miteinander gesprochen haben die
Präsidentin der Republik Moldau war das
vielen herzlichen Dank und alles Gute
vielen Dank
ja und sollte Putin das Land in welcher
Form auch immer destabilisieren und
einnehmen dann stünde Russland an der
Grenze zur Rumänien und damit an der
nato-außengrenze und mit der NATO geht
es jetzt auch bei dir weiter Hanna ja
denn darum ging es auch beim Besuch des
us-außenministers in der Türkei dort hat
sich blinken für einen schnellen
NATO-Beitritt von Schweden und Finnland
ausgesprochen dies würde die Sicherheit
eines jeden nato-mitglieds erhöhen
einschließlich der Türkei sagte er bei
einer Pressekonferenz mit seinem
Amtskollegen charuz
auch den türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan
dieser blockiert den Beitritt Schweden
seit Monaten und wirft dem Land vor
Terrororganisationen zu unterstützen
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
hat auf dem Truppenübungsplatz Munster
ukrainische Soldaten besucht dort werden
sie aktuell am Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 und
am Schützenpanzer Marder ausgebildet
historius erklärte dass der vorgesehene
Zeitplan eingehalten werde bis Ende März
würden die versprochenen Leoparden und
Marder an die Ukraine ausgeliefert dann
sei auch die Ausbildung abgeschlossen
in Berlin ist der zehntausenden
Erdbebenopfer in der Türkei und in
Syrien gedacht worden
Bundespräsident Steinmeier dankte den
Helferinnen und Helfern vor Ort und in
Deutschland euer Schmerz ist unser
Schmerz sagte Steinmeier wörtlich
deutschland stehe an der Seite der
Betroffenen appellierte zudem an die
politische Führung in Syrien humanitäre
Hilfe nicht zu blockieren
ja und erneut hat ein starkes Erdbeben
den Südosten der Türkei erschüttert der
türkischen Behörden hatte es eine Stärke
von 6,4 und das Epizentrum lag in der
Provinz hat hei laut dem türkischen
Innenminister wurden mindestens drei
Menschen getötet und mehr als 200
verletzt der Bürgermeister von hathai
rief ihr Twitter dazu auf sich von
einsturzgefährdeten Gebäuden
fernzuhalten aber Medienberichten war
das Leben auch in Syrien und Israel zu
spüren
nordkorea hat nach Angaben von Südkorea
und Japan erneut einen Raketentest
durchgeführt sein zwei ballistische
Raketen abgefeuert worden die im
Japanischen Meer gelandet sein erst am
Samstag hatte Pjöngjang eine
Interkontinentalrakete getestet auf
Antrag Japans wurden da wurde daraufhin
eine Dringlichkeitssitzung des
UN-Sicherheitsrats an diesem Abend
einberufen
die rechtsreligiöse Regierung um
Ministerpräsident netanyahoo treibt den
Umbau des Justizsystems weiter voran
trotz anhaltender Massenproteste erneut
versammelten sich Zehntausende während
in der Knesset unter Tumulten die erste
von drei Lesungen begann zudem wurden
Abgeordnete daran gehindert sich zur
Abstimmung zu begeben die Pläne sehen
vor das Urteile des höchsten Gerichts
von Parlament aufgehoben werden könnten
und die Politik größeren Einfluss auf
die Ernennung von Richterinnen und
Richtern erhältst
ja demonstrieren ist ein gutes Stichwort
seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges auf die Ukraine versucht
auch die EU ja etwas zu demonstrieren
und zwar Einigkeit das beliebteste und
bereits neunmal gezogene Instrumente für
sind Sanktionen doch wer genauer
hinschaut der wird erkennen seit Monaten
klappt das weder so richtig mit der
Einigkeit noch mit der vor einem Jahr
vollmundig angekündigten Schlagkraft der
Bestrafung wer sich bei Toilettenpapier
schnell einig ist aber bei Diamanten und
Brennelementen zaudert der muss sich
hinterfragen lassen heute von Florian
neuhahn
wenn er in die Ukraine einmarschiert
werden die Konsequenzen für seine
Wirtschaft verheerend sein
wir sind uns alle einig dass an dem
militärische Aggression schwerwiegende
Konsequenzen nach sich zöge
unsere Sanktionen können sehr hart sein
ein Jahr nach diesen Drohungen treffen
sich die Außenminister der EU mal wieder
in Brüssel es geht wie immer in diesem
Jahr um Sanktionen darum ob die
Versprechen von damals eingehalten
wurden oder was dafür noch fehlt
Winnie wir brauchen jetzt ein zehntes
Sanktionspaket wir müssen die
Schlupflöcher schließen die in unseren
bisherigen Sanktionen existieren
Rückblick das erste Sanktionspaket
beschließt die EU schon am Tag vor
Kriegsausbruch am Ende des Jahres zählt
man in Brüssel 9 Pakete wobei die
Diskussionen schwieriger die Abstände
zwischen den Paketen immer größer werden
wichtigste Sanktionen bisher der
Ausschluss russischer Banken vom
Zahlungssystem Swift das Einfuhrverbot
für russische Kohle und das für
russisches Rohöl es sind insgesamt die
schärfsten Sanktionen die die EU jemals
beschlossen hat doch die russische
Wirtschaft zwingen sie in diesem Jahr
nicht in die Knie
nach heutiger offizieller Zahl
schrumpfte sie im letzten Jahr bloß um
2,1%
russland hat sich schneller und besser
angepasst an diese neue Situation es
wurden viele Handelsströme umgelenkt es
wird jetzt viel mehr aus China
importiert und auch viel mehr Öl nach
Indien und China exportiert und das hat
eben dafür gesorgt dass der Einbruch
jetzt deutlich geringer ausgefallen ist
zumal Europa ständig Kompromisse finden
muss zwischen reiner Lehre und eigener
Abhängigkeit zum Beispiel heute
russische Brennstäbe wohl auch im
geplanten 10 Paket nicht enthalten sie
werden gebraucht für Atomkraftwerke wie
dieses in Ungarn vielleicht nur ein
Nebenschauplatz jetzt sagen Experten
gehe es vor allem darum die bisherigen
Sanktionen durchzuhalten
es ist klar auch schon von anderen
Fällen wo Sanktionen eingeführt wurden
dass Sanktionen Zeit brauchen um die
Wirkung zu entfalten lassen sie uns
schon umbenennen sind wie ein Gift wie
er sehen irgendwas es wird langsam aber
es wirkt unumkehrbar
Europas Sanktionen gegen Russland werden
bald ein Jahr alt und mit ihnen ein
großes Missverständnis dass sie alleine
reichen würden diesen Krieg zu beenden
die deutsche Wirtschaft dürfte nach
Einschätzung der Bundesbank in eine
winterrezession rutschen sie geht davon
aus dass die Wirtschaftsleistung auch im
ersten Quartal 2023 schrumpft und das
Valerie Halle in Frankfurt obwohl die
Zeichen ja zuletzt durchaus auf
Entspannung standen oder ja standen sie
aber die Bundesbank ist tatsächlich
etwas pessimistischer sie rechnet mit
einer sogenannten technischen Rezession
und davon spricht man ja wenn zwei
Quartale infolge die Konjunktur
schrumpft und das wäre eben der Fall
wenn das Wachstum auch im ersten Quartal
dieses Jahr noch mal niedriger ausfällt
aber und da sticht die Bundesbank dann
wirklich hervor für sie ist in den
kommenden Monaten auch keine wesentliche
Besserung in Sicht denn fürs Gesamtjahr
erwarten die Experten in Frankfurt einen
Rückgang der Wirtschaftsleistung dabei
zählen die Notenbanker vier Belastungen
für die Wirtschaft auf eine schwächere
Industrieproduktion sinkende Nachfrage
aus dem Ausland eine sich abkühlende
Bauwirtschaft und ein Zurückgehen
privater Verbrauch wegen der steigenden
Preise auch bei der Inflation erwartet
die Bundesbank keine schnelle Besserung
schon allein wegen der hohen
Tarifabschlüsse und der satten
Lohnforderungen denn befürchtet wird das
Unternehmen wegen höherer Personalkosten
ihre Verkaufspreise weiter anheben
könnten sogenannte zweitrundene Effekte
welche die Inflation dann weiter
anheizen dürften alles in allem mal die
Bundesbank ein negatives Bild von 2023
als die Bundesregierung und eine ganze
Reihe von Ökonomen sie halten ein
leichtes Wachstum für dieses Jahr für
durchaus realistisch mal sehen wer am
Ende Recht behält danke Valerie für
diese Einschätzung
der Sportvorstand des ersten fC Nürnberg
Dieter Hecking übernimmt bis zum
Saisonende auch den Trainerposten des
Zweitligisten zuvor hatte sich der
abstiegsgefährdete Club von Trainer
Markus weinzier getrennt und da wir war
unter anderem eine Null zu fünf
Niederlage gegen den ersten fC
Heidenheim am Sonntag
Putin küsst den Teufel ein Mull Arsch
der in den Venen Haaren einer jungen
Frau verstrickt ist und ein
Wirtschaftsminister der Kröten schlucken
muss Katar lässt grüßen Karneval darf
Karneval will Stellung beziehen und das
taten die Jecken und jeckenen die Narren
und narrinnen dann auch nach zwei Jahren
Zwangspause in einer wie immer bunten
kreativen und zugespitzten Art und Weise
in Köln gab es noch etwas Besonderes zu
feiern seit 200 Jahren schallt es nun
dort und in der Umgebung kölle Alaaf
zum ersten Mal in 200 Jahren
organisiertem Karneval der
Rosenmontagszug beginnt auf der
sogenannten Köln Deutz auf der
Düsseldorfer Rheinseite
wunderbar im Dom im Hintergrund das
Wetter spielt halbwegs mit jetzt freuen
uns auf den Zug
nach zwei Jahren Pause ein
Jubiläumsumzug und auch in Köln
politische Botschaften in aller Klarheit
der Kampf der Frauen um ihre Freiheit im
Iran der Müller mit dem blutigen Schwert
und der heruntergelassenen Hose
die neuen starken Frauen in der
katholischen Kirche und Schweinepriester
hinter Gittern starker Tobak wie das bis
zum Köln sofort anmerkte oder auch
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck der vor Katar
einknickt weil Energie dann doch
Vorhaltung geht und in jedem Zug heute
ein Hauptthema Putin und sein
teuflisches Spiel mit dem Feuer des
Krieges wer dafür durch den Wolf gedreht
wird ist ihm egal
Putin auch das Top-Thema im Düsseldorfer
Zug zum Beispiel als Blutbad neben der
Diktator der sich im Leid der Ukraine
wohl fühlt
der Wagen der hinter uns steht der
bezieht glaube ich eindeutig Stellung
der Zeit halt Putin im Blutbad eindeutig
ist auch klar was mit der Badewanne
gemeint ist die keine Farben also diesen
Wagen versteht man auch mit 1,5 Promille
drin aber es gibt noch so viel mehr die
Frage wer der Klima Terrorist ist junge
protestierende oder grimmige Autos wird
gestellt und was in Köln fehlt ein Blick
auf den umstrittenen Kardinal Wölki ist
in Düsseldorf selbstverständlich und
auch hier der Kampf der iranischen
Frauen gegen sehen Sie selbst das solche
Wagen Muslime hier ärgern könnten weiß
der Baumeister
in der Satiriker muss frei sein und muss
angstfrei sein und klar kann irgendwas
passieren das kann immer was passieren
wenn schon viele Wagen gemacht zum Thema
islamistischen Terror aber ein
Dachdecker kann auch vom Dach fallen ist
einfach Berufsrisiko das müssen wir
einfach in Kauf nehmen in Mainz strahlt
auch die Sonne auf den Zug die Feiernden
nach zwei Jahren Pause hell begeistert
ich habe mich seit Wochen auf den Tag so
sich die letzten Jahre dass es nicht
stattfinden konnte und auch hier bekommt
Krieg sehr Putin von einer ukrainischen
Sonnenblume die passende Antwort auf
seinen Angriff ganz nach dem Motto des
Mainzer Zuges wenn es doch nur helfen
würde
na dann von uns noch einen Jecken Narren
und überhaupt sagen wir mal einfach
allen Karnevalisten noch viel Spaß ja
und dann noch der Hinweis auf unser
heute journal Update 0:05 mit Nazan
gökte mir dann machen sie es gut wo auch
immer Sie sind
[Musik]
guten Abend wussten Sie wie wir ein
Messdaten kommen zum Beispiel so wir
lassen Balance steigen an denen eine
radiosonde hängt darin Messgeräte für
Temperatur Luftdruck feuchte sowie ein
Sender der die Daten zur Erde funkt
gefüllt ist der Ballon mit leichtem Gas
Helium oder Wasserstoff mit der Höhe
nimmt der Luftdruck ab so dehnt sich der
Ballon mehr und mehr aus der Durchmesser
kann auf etwa 13 Meter wachsen
Wetterballons können bis in die
Stratosphäre steigen mehr als 30 km hoch
dabei wird die Hülle so dünn dass sie
nach etwa 90 Minuten platzt Tage lang
ist herum irren ausgeschlossen am
Fallschirm segelt die Sonde zurück zur
Erde
an 14 Stationen in Deutschland lässt der
Deutsche Wetterdienst regelmäßig Radio
Sonden aufsteigen die Flugsicherung ist
immer im Bilde und jetzt von den
Messungen zurück zur Prognose hier
entwickelt sich gerade über dem Nordmeer
ein neues Tief und das wird uns zum Ende
der Woche deutlich tiefere Temperaturen
bringen heute Nacht fällt erstmal noch
Regen und zwar zwischen der Nordseeküste
und der Lausitz an der Ostsee ist es
vergleichsweise trocken klar wird es
dagegen am Alpenrand und dort auch kalt
da sinken die Temperaturen bis -1° unter
den dichteren Wolken bleibt die Nacht
mild bei 9 bis 5 Grad und doch morgen
wird Tag hält das Regenwald wacker durch
es liegt dann zwischen dem Emsland und
der Lausitz die Sonne werden sie mal in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Schleswig-Holstein sehen richtig sonnig
wird aber hier am Alpenrand und am
Oberrhein da steigen die Werte bis 16
Grad an der Ostsee sind es nur acht Grad
am Aschermittwoch ziehen von besten
Regenwolken an die breiten sich
Donnerstag ostwärts aus und am Freitag
wird es so kühl dass es in
Norddeutschland viel Regen reicht
tschüss